this is dipper versus manliness the code
for this one
mr. cesarean will be out next week
mr. AB bash will substitute do you get
that
no oh you've seen this show but are you
asking me III don't remember that one if
that's a thing so totally went over my
head that one so if somebody knows the
comments go ahead let us know now
they're all gonna be that I'm sure but
anywho find out a month from that yes so
this is dipper vs. manliness exactly
what it sounds like
dipper doesn't feel he's manly enough he
fails this this little petty pointed man
machine I one of those things we squeeze
and measures your strength so he finds a
magnet or who take man cave yeah it
takes him to the man cave with all the
other testosterone and whatever the
other ones were to at or yeah I know and
beardy and they tried to turn them into
a man and the final big test is that yes
to go destroy multi-bear and the first
time I saw multi-bear I was like oh oh
it's okay
Marin Cilic okay let's just disco girl
what's fine um what's where I got
against the abba-baba-baba snot girl
'i'm just okay oh my god I don't like
him at all
I will admit to listening to Ace of Base
back III told so when I was gonna review
mommy at some point and it's like yeah
I'll get to it I'll get to it it's like
damn it it's like I so don't want no
they don't like ABBA
but okay so he but they find out they
like the same song and so he feels he
doesn't have to kill him and he pretty
much tells them he's not gonna do it and
they're like let's build something it
destroyed you know just all the really
extreme manly stereotype meanwhile I
like the duality of Mabel trying to fix
yeah make it more
I keep going to say crumpled Stan skip
yeah and that's turning out to be a
failure well looks like dipper is
succeeding but then in the end
everything works out but that was my
favorite Isis like I know you like
fixing things lazy susan so here's my
uncle he needs some real while of those
like wow I loved it before and after a
picture in the before picture actually
looks better than yeah that's a good
moral it's like yeah he did the right he
did do the manly thing by standing up
for himself and yeah oh yeah Alfred
Molina is the UH as mandatory right it
doesn't check the credits I think cuz I
keep noticing as I'm watching these like
these big names pop up and notice um I
know it is there simply not notice no no
I did not know is that the guy who does
grunkle Stan does also answers is also
the Creator then I didn't know you yeah
I've never seen this before and I had to
point that out
um I always thought it was like the guy
sounds like Beetlejuice to me like the
enemy of Beetlejuice I sort of thought I
just sort of thought maybe I was that
guy what's Alex Hirsch but now I know so
yeah you know it's funny going into this
one I was saying like oh you're in for a
treat this one is so great I watch I was
like it was still good just but it
wasn't as great as I remember it may be
the first episode that I'm just like
yeah that was all right yeah I guess the
plot was mostly predictable for this
show and it was like Oh a bunch of manly
stereotypes anyone said it's one of the
stories that I feel like I've seen so
many times in other cartoons that even
though it was funny it just was not one
of those that I was like really
extremely interested I'm just like yeah
I've seen this plotline I think it's the
fact I think like some of the jokes I
like there there's a few jokes I'm like
wow is that ingenious like I love you
know the ancient one but we are coming
in he's just the offering that's
ingenious there's there's a couple of
really mr. nipples were really
but yeah you're right I have what was it
I've x4 ABS yeah this for nipple like
three Y chromosome three Y chromosomes
six Adam's apples something like it yeah
now it and there was some very funny
jokes is just the plot overall didn't
greet me even though the jokes were
still funny is that I don't know I mean
I mean wasn't a bad episode no no no but
I get the feeling this is gonna be a lot
like Avatar where we're gonna be like
there's not really bad episodes it's
just the good episodes are so good that
the ones that are okay you know you're
just like yeah that's honestly I've yet
to see like an actual bad episode where
I'm like that was bad I wish I didn't
see that it they're they're like also
enjoy this episode ends up being rock
bottom like I should be so lucky
yeah yeah but ya know looking back it
was a record the TV is over here which
is why I keep like looking I realize I
keep looking or pointing it yeah there's
just a picture got it um pause so my eye
keeps darting over to the TV as we're
talking yeah you know we should turn
that off cuz yeah I keep looking at that
- I actually damn I just realized that
like the whole town we're just gonna be
talking to the audience like this that's
like why why are we doing that well now
know what you should put like a little
picture over where the lamp is and like
of what we're pong I still went over
there Eve as you were saying that once
cuz you've got this it's because you are
light hits us by instinct is to have the
camera right in front of us yeah what
the light hitters because we're getting
a really harsh shadow it's but it's no I
like I I think I look very pretty I mean
bad way mm-hmm but I know it was one of
those like I'm watching this could be
because we're marathoning this I think
this is gonna be last one for the day
cuz like we just did six episodes in a
row I think I'm running out of things to
say like I was like yeah that's good I
don't know what else to say about this
episode um yeah I think the whole in
order to be like I want pancakes I know
that yes they did me pancakes so the cop
eating the pancakes on yeah yeah I'm
just like I just say I'm like shit
pancakes um yeah like I said I mean we
sort of know this moral in order to be a
man you don't always have to do the
manly stereotypes Arabiya want me not to
do the one that leaves therio tights you
know all this stuff sir see it before it
not a bad moral and it lets us a nice
creativity but yeah I think it's maybe a
few more jokes like there's about three
more like real holy smokes where those
really funny jokes if probably would
then even stronger like wow this is up
to par with the other ones I'd like to
thank you that this is one of those
shows that in some ways reinforces
gender roles and certain stereotypes
about boys and girls but it works
because they each have a distinct
personality well I think there's you
know I get I like I actually find her
more interesting half the time than he
is like I'm just like I want to find out
how that brain works it's fascinating
well I think it's something where
there's still lion hamster ball yeah I
mean there's still like whatever we
whatever any comedian ramus is like you
know all men are this all women are
visit we mean every single man people
and every single woman is like that know
if we're talking about broad strokes and
sort of culturally stop well it's funny
because in some ways this does use broad
strokes but they lead us but there
occurs so interesting that it just works
yeah they don't know what salting they
seem very complementary and not watching
Barbie and Ken here even though you know
she's really a girl that like almost in
a stereotypical way like in some
cartoons and he's really a boy though I
guess and like she's been this one he's
trying to man up and everything him but
it like because the characters are so
well written it doesn't matter like if
you write interesting characters you can
make your character almost anything you
want yeah I think there's a say that you
know there is gonna be a pattern to
certain cultures or people or gender
whatever that you know majority of the
crowd are gonna follow but if you don't
it's not like there's something wrong
with you when you're not a real whatever
it's like no it's just you there is this
pattern though that happens and if you
don't follow it that's fine there's
nothing wrong with it but it's fun to
make fun of that's what comedy does you
know it makes fun of these funny
patterns that just keep going and going
and going or they stop or whatever
if they continue or if they change and
that's that's part of the fun and they
don't seem like insulting or if they do
insult it's always like hey we did the
other side too like you know anytime
it's like you make fun of like you know
something that's really feminine if they
make fun of something very masculine
this whole episode is mocking
masculinity you know and it's funny you
if you give your characters if your
characters feel real and they have a
real personality III don't care all the
time about the damn philosophy by like I
said I've seen some movies with really
Pro feminist messages that I thought
were fuckin insufferable hmm and I've
seen some of the same that we're like
I'm like wow this movie is incredible
and the difference is how you write the
characters is it just simply a
well-written character I won't name
names on some of these films I've seen
but you know and it works absolutely
there are like movies where they'll have
like really your classic gender
stereotype you know divisions and
sometimes I'm just like oh man this
really just sucks and other times I'm
like no it really works because the
characters are well-written like that's
what should be the driving force
yeah the character is what leads the
identity not the raise the gender of any
of that stuff yeah so as I said when
it's all said and done I find her the
most interesting yeah no she's versus
like I think another good example the
opposite way was at this stage in the
game we just saw hero 6 I know this will
be running later but you know on the
team they had this girl she was a nerdy
girl but she was like a girly girl
listen man and that's all there was to
her there was just like no personality
and that's a case where I'm just like
okay so you have your pretty-in-pink
type who's just goofy and t but i just
didn't find anything really fascinating
about it the way the character was
written you know others show yes um so
yeah I think it's a I think you nail or
it's like the character leads the
identity yeah you know and you know
that's where even if someone is like a
reinforcements something that you know
is stereotypical and a stereotypical it
if they have a good identity in an
understandable and relatable identity
it's they explain why it's what
separates things like Miyazaki
environmental Pro environmental message
movies from
goli or Captain Planet yeah yeah like
you know it's just there was a concept
of like let's write a good story first
the fact that it happens to be
pro-environmental can be a part of it
but you have to have a good story to
begin with ya know I tell ya that was
just gonna bring up the whole
environmental element like you know it's
good to look after the environment I
mean it's we're not anti-environment how
you even anti it's like I'm anti being
in this spot you know it's like just a
key really the anti environment you know
yeah mmm Miyazaki Captain Planet in Fern
Gully technically to me they're
preaching to the choir
oh my god I already grew a planet after
I watched Captain Planet or Fern Gully
I basically want to burn down a
rainforest for ya just so this is like
yeah whereas I watch to be as a Q movies
exact observes like hey he's right okay
yeah well I said I have a time at the
blue puts these by the way not book what
if I innovate show yeah I don't hate
them movie as much as you but I know but
yeah so there you go there's our R and I
think sometimes we talked about the show
spawn discuss yes what is it okay I it's
a good show but after well it's like you
want to have things to talk about okay
this one do you have like a song yeah
there's so many episodes of this we're
gonna have to get through it we're not
always gonna be like ooh let's get into
the nitty-gritty of like some are just
gonna be I need a break what do you say
we both take some time
go change our clothes maybe our hair
will be a little different maybe the
lighting and positioning of the camera
will be different perhaps yes and we
just go from there
all right sounds good to me okay see you
next week
I mean damn